[Music]
foreign
is being rushed to the ICU for the
second time in weeks she's been
struggling to breathe doctors say the
air pollution has triggered her asthma
it's also taking a toll on her family
the doctors suggest we leave Delhi
because it will be difficult for her to
live here I have already spent a lot of
money on her treatment relocation will
be expensive I'm really struggling but
will have to find a way her life is more
important than money
new delhi's air has become toxic once
again pollution tends to increase at the
onset of winter While most of the smog
is from Vehicles some is caused by fires
like these
for weeks farmers in neighboring states
have been burning the straw stubble that
remains after harvesting the government
in New Delhi has imposed restrictions
non-essential construction has been
stopped and many older vehicles are
banned but people say it's having little
effect
[Music]
I have shortness of breath I cough and
my eyes sting as if someone had put
chilies in them this has been going on
for a month and a half
current air pollution levels are several
times higher than the safe limit doctors
are calling it a public health emergency
with many long and short-term effects
studies suggest poor air quality is
causing more than 50 000 premature
deaths in the city every year and
reducing life expectancy by nearly a
decade
people with pre-existing respiratory
conditions children and senior citizens
are most vulnerable hospitals estimate
the number of patients has doubled in a
month and doctors say everyone is
affected
even people who have no exposure to you
know smoking or have no his family
history of respiratory diseases now we
see that many of them come with problems
of the lung where their x-rays look like
they have had like like a smoker's law
they also warn of other health effects
infections last longer there's a higher
risk of heart attacks and strokes it
also impacts mental well-being doctors
say authorities need to do more to
reduce pollution as it's the only way to
reverse some of the damage Al Jazeera
New Delhi